hey girls Nicky Jam listen to Monday to
Monday you're gonna love it
Nicky Jam I only like the process it's
the only thing for me like I'm addicted
to there's nothing else I like I don't
like stuff I don't want stuff I just
want the legacy of the process you know
what I mean
and that's why yours is so good compared
to other things like when it's just like
this I'm only about the process I always
put myself in the process like that's
why I jump from different businesses
like once I won wine I bounced because I
was like what am I gonna do just milk it
for the riches that's what most people
do they they only want to do the sheep
to get to the stuff they're willing to
put in the work for the Lamborghini or
the girls or the chains but once they
get it they're out that's why so many
people lose once they win I know I know
that's my guy I love that dude he's a
good guy like good people he is sharp
he's got great instincts that's a really
good way to put it what's really
interesting though is it's your time now
right like you were born at the right
time like you guys are taking over the
world like the whole like I'm sure like
the the Latin invasion of America is
forever over it's not going backwards
it's only like this is just the
beginning
people don't get it like the
demographics
it's just mad it's over it's over it's
really cool it's really cool yeah one of
the coolest things to me was when you
were talking about how you went to
Columbia and you were like going hard
after YouTube till I get your numbers up
and like you were really true like got
all yours when I went to Columbia I saw
there was 65 million people and my
career was in a downfall so I said if I
can make this country love me and I
could be the number one National if I
could make a national hit number one
national hit in this country I'll get 65
million people to back me up and if I
get 65 million people to love me
other people from other countries like
why this guy has so many views you know
I gotta be straight up with you straight
up real quick it's my favorite thing
about you how you you understand that
that's a talent that will never go away
from you right because whether it's
Columbia or snapchat or eSports or this
famous person it's just the math of
attention to have the understanding to
get up go execute like that whoo yeah I
mean I never will go away from you
that's that's the same game it's all I
ever do
it's just attention exactly exactly and
that that's that's the thing I had to
study the country and make the country
love me not because not me you're not
being from that country and not being
active in the music in the moment
because Columbia wasn't into reggaeton
music but it wasn't into the guys that
were active in the moment right so I had
to go there and make make them fall in
love with me but it was easy cuz they
were like you're this guy's living in
our country he loves us you know say why
it wasn't living in the state so I
wasn't living in Puerto Rico and he's
coming over here and I started doing
videos 15-second videos and I'm like I'm
over here in the streets of meta-gene
walking and don don don don I'm doing
this and I just bought my new mazda6 and
normally rappers it's brag about
Bentleys and I'm happy cuz I have a car
again so so they fell in love with my
story and and and it worked exactly how
I wanted to I didn't have one number one
hit I had six number-one hits in
Colombia national hits and my views were
incredible and I started jumping from
funny I think about hunting and farming
now the key for you to have like a 50
hundred year career like at this at this
new level because you've had a career
you need to be very thoughtful of
forever giving love to that country know
everything you guys right oh the
number-one thing for you to be able to
win in Asia on Mars on a new platform
you need to be real thoughtful about how
you continue to give love there forever
yeah you have to have you know what you
should do you should uh you should make
the day you put your first video up in
Colombia like a an app like a holiday
within your world and your mind and
you're a fan and like literally always
do something special on that day you
should go back look at the first day you
posted something on YouTube and Columbia
if that if that's what you give credit
for when you first started look at that
date and you should throw a free concert
every year on that date for life as
awesome really awesome another thing is
like what he was saying about how humble
he was in in Columbia and like what Gary
loves is the lyrics and the story and I
know that you were saying in Puerto Rico
with more about beats and this and that
no I understand like I don't understand
like beats and producers like that well
I really don't like I get it like if I
feel like if the music like I get it but
I know that I'm not thoughtful about
that but the story that's that's nothing
at for me it's everything like for me
that's for me like I think everybody has
their own thing for me
and then the story of the purse that's
why I usually I love people's first
albums because that's their origin story
that's their first issue of the comic
book right that's when you're telling
people like this is what happened and
this is what happened I think it takes a
lot for somebody to have that second or
third like it's the person that knows
how to story tell of what they're going
through because the first one that's
your truth it's kind of how my keynotes
work on YouTube my business talks like
they used to be easy because I just tell
you I was born in Russia and lived in a
studio apartment this many family
members so this is like how I grew up
like you know but then then it got
harder because that was established and
now you got to come back with some hits
yeah you started quino's the same way
you started your album like telling the
story like you know like everything so
now what cuz it's white hot right now
you guys must all be like okay we need
to be like well you know my mentality is
first of all in my music and the general
music about reggaeton is it was it was
kind of hard you know to work and do big
things cuz they didn't you know they saw
as a street singers you know I'm saying
so normally like you see a Ricky Martin
or Luis FONSI or any it would be easier
for them to you know work with brands
and sponsorship and all stuff like that
so I'm wait I'm breaking those
boundaries you know I'm saying I'm
pushing it and I'm being the first you
know I'm just I just worked I just
signed with Hublot I just signed with
I'm doing the Netflix thing I'm doing I
got something big working with will
I'm doing the movies I did the movie
with Vin Diesel I did I'm doing I'm
doing things for my music and I want to
be like you could say the Jennifer Lopez
of my music you know what I'm saying I
want because I'm bilingual I could I'm
good acting and and and that's what I'm
trying to do JLo money's interesting
money it is but you know what's amazing
about her and amazing about because I've
been really digging into you last couple
months uh work
I just wish JLo I get so mad at culture
like people when when I hear J Lo's name
literally the first thing I think of is
a working gangster she is she hustles
she works and like when everybody talks
about her like they talk about her being
a celebrity or they're like whatever and
I'm like such disrepair about working
99.9999 percent of people Will Smith is
working the reason you got something
Bruce Smith is Wilson smart he realized
the game he was playing for the last two
decades was time was up you can't make
the same movie 15 times in a row and get
paid 20 million exactly this is game he
looked around it felt authentic you got
plenty of attention in the game your can
pump because he's a an icon one plus one
equals two right exactly yeah listen to
me I'm telling you right now cuz I can
tell that you know everything so I don't
have that much to give that first that
first day you made a piece of content
throw that free concert you're only
krypton my kryptonite right now is if
you forget about Columbia oh you know
I'm being dead serious though I have
seen the songs everywhere you're so
you're so natural to grow you know like
you're like me like you're your natural
move is to grow you're gonna win a shoe
you're gonna do the same you're gonna
rep you know you're gonna run this same
racket over and over right like you're
gonna win China the same way you're
gonna win some new platform the same way
this is over now that you've tasted it
like it's over you're just gonna rinse
and repeat and the only vulnerability is
if it feels manipulated it is choule
nobody you know even the way you talk
about you know what's funny I wouldn't
even given you the advice you're like me
you're transparent
there's a lot of people who did what you
did that would never say I decided to go
to Columbia for that reason 65 million
if I can make them love me it weren't
exactly you have to understand if you're
on the other side in Columbia
humans are cynical they're like oh you
just can't got it so you need to go hard
the other way no of course I mean you
know Columbia's come to the states that
you know to look for their dream I went
I went to Columbia to get my dream to go
back I got they looking for the American
dream and I was looking for the
Colombian dream for the world a nose by
the way your models right sit what do I
keep saying about a country in South
America what's my new thing where do I
want to be famous nope
Peru yes like this I want to be a famous
everywhere but but the reason I keep
saying Peru and I haven't I have no idea
how many people live there it's more
it's not a joke it's more of a religion
which is what you did is one of the
first examples of like this works for
everybody man like this is the right
model like if you're a creator right now
out there for music or videos taking a
step back especially if you're young and
you can live anywhere and if you're
willing to live humbly taking a step
back and looking at different places
around the world because YouTube and
Facebook and these platforms work
everywhere
Saudi Arabia now with snapchat and with
this new prince like every day I wish I
was like 24 and had no responsibilities
and no family I'd pick my ass up and go
to Saudi Arabia right now and [ __ ]
kill it that's what you did me that's
what I felt when I went to Colombia
exactly
you had an even a bigger advantage
because you already had an up and a down
so you had a chip exactly even better
than being a young kid you had
experience and a chip
I lost my ego no he wrecked once you
good once you triple down on humility
and still have ego and hunger exactly as
long as humilities just point one bigger
than you go you it's game over that's
what will has all that Will Smith has
just done is he let his humility go a
little bit further than Zeo that's why
he was willing to vlog and be on myspace
on myspace on Instagram the fact that he
had the humility to go on there most a
list stars don't want to go to Instagram
and YouTube because they have to start
at zero and there's other people out
there like you and that have more
followers they don't have the humility
humility I have a question for you
obviously you told me that uh you get
you you get bored and you want to do new
things and new things but have you are
out of all the success you already have
you never you never just like I'm tired
like you never feel tired yet I say yet
more you know never bored never bored
I'm - what takes the board away is doing
something nobody's doing always doing
yeah if I get like I'm pretty
disciplined which is why I can build big
companies but and they'll tell you I'll
just make up new that isn't big like I'm
building a twitch studio right outside
my office that's me being bored right
just need a little action a little hit
of something new but I keep 89 92
percent got it and that's that it's side
dishes my steak and my chicken it's
proper but sometimes I need some
cauliflower or some you know something
new right side dishes keep me going plus
I'm just great honestly I'm grateful
like to me I'm just grateful which never
gets me down or negative or bored or
just grateful I'm just hungry
you do love yourself I love myself I
love myself that's a really good way to
put it and for most people that's a
difficult thing to say cuz the world
doesn't accept that super well but
that's the answer for everybody in this
room and everybody behind that camera
my biggest thing if you look at my
content I'm trying to get people to love
themselves
the way you love yourself is you become
a hundred percent accountability for
your shortcomings
cuz everybody everybody in here is done
done every one of us it's got
shortcomings so first you get there but
yeah man I do love myself because my mom
made me that way and and no voice has
been able to penetrate me to tell me the
alternative incredible you know it's it
I I believe in that a lot about loving
yourself I mean and it was hard for me
because I came from my mom she left me
when I was eight years old she was a
drug addict and a prostitute my dad was
a drug addict himself and it's kind of
hard for you to love yourself when you
come from that situation but I was
trying to blame the world when I when I
was in drugs and I was an all messed up
and blame my parents and when I started
to love myself everything changed for me
I mean I was tired of I was tired of
looking at myself and then blaming
people insane my life was a piece and
and nothing was happening for me so one
day I said okay first I was fat I was
like really fat I was waiting almost 300
pounds I was taking to almost Perks a
day in the perks there's not like other
drugs that will make you not eat the
perks will make you eat more than so I
was like the worst at least take the
weight off me you know so I was a fat
drug addict and I was tired of that and
I realized that when I started losing
weight the attitude of the people when
they started seeing me was different it
was a different vibe it was like hey
Nikki it was good ain't when I go eat
something they didn't say that when I
was fat and all messed up in drugs they
want to go they want to take me out cuz
they felt I look good so everything so I
said okay this is the beginning how did
that even start like what's this who
like what did you see or what like I'm
always fascinated by that the tipping
point okay what did I see for the weight
thing mm-hmm I think I think well first
of all I was uh I was I was out of
Denny's actually eating and that fat
girl came to me and said what happened
to me and it pissed me off and that's
the same it happened to you you fat W
mean I was eating and I got fat no she
knew me because I was the music you know
I'm saying and you gotta understand I
was so skinny when I was
famous in puerto rico the first time so
when I got fat out was the form you
could say like this guy's not the same
guy so obviously it's ok for a fat girl
to tell me what happened you know I'm
saying but it was like you know and it
felt bad it can't feel kind of bad you
know and I was like and then I said to
myself what happened you know saying and
and and then I said ok so I said I'm
gonna start with the weight thing and
then when I first and I started eating
like the the cleanest thing in every
menu honestly like like it's funny it
doesn't you know that was your story my
big thing is like bald short dudes and
like overweight people like like you've
got to figure out how to like not make
anything else the way you justify your
hat like it's got to be an inside game
like listen being healthy is just a good
idea to live longer but it's crazy to me
being secure and being insecure
it comes in every shape and size it's
wild
I'm just thinking about some friends who
are both overweight underweight rich
poor you tall short athletic not like
you know and you go through that in life
like I remember somewhere in high school
and then early college when I was like
wait a minute
pretty people are insecure too of course
most and JIT just runs the gamut oh yeah
you just got I'm just desperate to get
people to stop judging themselves that's
that's what you see a lot you know
saying it's crazy and I mean musicians
are the worst like you could see emeriti
gonna be number one right now in the
billboard and depressed you know what
honestly what the whole team here is
there anything I can help with is there
anything we can help with like from
anybody's perspective your perspective
or anybody on the team that might have
one I mean I mean there's a lot one of
the things natural like just so you know
me a little bit my natural default is I
love to give first cuz I don't expect
forgiving
I don't expect in return and I know it
also works in the end and if it works
too out of the left like he'll tell you
what ten years went to this journey yeah
you know using Miami so there's that
yeah I'm there a lot yep yes
know one thing really important please
now like I was saying I was I'm trying
to be like the first from my gender of
music to work with these bars smuggle
work with these brands you know I'm
saying so I mean I've been working with
you already like in Latin America but I
would love to be the Latin face of you
know I'm saying in your world in the
u.s. sometimes and sometimes you know
it's kind of hard being a reggaeton
artists you know I'm saying so you know
if you guys can help me with anything of
that it'll be awesome
it's not it's not at all but sometimes
Almighty we know what it is we know we
all know what it is
let's go different route I think you're
making a mistake
let me explain you're not first one
you're making the least mistakes but
it's funny in some places you're going
real New Wave in other places you're
looking at a traditional I don't think
you should do because he's not gonna do
anything for you except be a short-term
check and I get it like I grew up with
Michael Jackson and we all know where he
sits I get it let me throw a different
one at you I think you should be
thinking about getting equity in a
start-up beverage like dirty lemon who's
smart enough to know that you're exactly
what they need you get a point of the
company on the back end they market you
properly not on dumb billboards she's
doubt Vennela out right and you win
twice to me you've Pat you know what you
and I have guys as their mentality is
that we don't need you you're already
organic thank you it's funny you know
what's funny it's not even that they
think that they need you or they don't
need you they don't know how valuable
you are right and then it's just like
what and more importantly I think we all
have to start debating how valuable they
are yeah
make sense like what's good about you
get paid and you get national exposure
you can get national exposure now your
[ __ ] YouTube videos are seen by a
hell of a lot more than every [ __ ]
commercial that runs this year globally
combined let's just take a second I want
everybody here to take a second and
listen to me real carefully your video
that you posted two weeks ago is
consumed more consumed not aired there's
a lot of commercials being aired nobody
watching them I just think you need to
get yours your value worth I think you
need to start thinking about like how
much leverage you have for you to be the
next JLo within this you can't do the
same blueprint that JLo did I gotta go
my wrath
you got to play a twenty eighteen to
twenty twenty three route you need to be
worried about kids that are playing on
Twitch and getting your music into their
channels you need to be thinking about
startup brands that are going direct to
consumer that are targeting the Latin
American consumer you need to be doing
you you need to reverse it they need you
and their check is getting less and less
interesting thank God right make it a
couple dollars and more importantly the
more you realize how much or how little
you actually need reason I'm dangerous
is I don't need to make a lot of money
every year which means I'm putting it
the energy into the bank giving myself
long-term leverage so you got the number
of the lemon company you saying so I
will be happy to help you need to look
at all of it there may be a very
authentic personal you start with
authenticity like if you drink an orange
soda like we need to look at fountas us
strategy first you want to talk about a
brand that could really get popping
because of you it needs to like Fanta
should team up with you and three four
others
they could be off to the races like
Fanta is the most interesting soda brand
to me because it's actually culturally
relevant outside the US they want to do
more business in the US but they don't
have the right faces so I think you have
the options I think you have the
leverage down it's all so new it happens
so fast the second time around you have
to be thoughtful about it but I'd go
backwards I would literally
the team sit down and think about
everything you actually like and just
know that you could actually jam with
them because then it's gonna be a better
relationship anyway cuz it's not a check
it's authentic music and whether that's
a Kleenex or a sneaker or what-have-you
and anything anything and if it's
neutral like if you don't give up then I
would go to something new not old like
you better really like for me if I
started from the beginning you need to
love Hublot like love it love it if not
I take a step back
I mean you listen there's more ears on
your music right now than jay-z's music
when he dropped that song it's just it's
real it's hard to comprehend cuz it all
changed and so when you when you deploy
humility like you're deploying it's
sometimes hard to wrap your head around
that's true
but like you can build the next few blow
with one mention good you could now you
can't do that for every category you
gotta be thoughtful
sometimes it's good to take the check
sometimes it's good to have the back end
sometimes it's good to floss I get it
but you need to be really thoughtful
about your brand strategy and it needs
to be forward-thinking not what has
happened yeah and if you own a part of
something like that
you'll be like looked at as the business
guy you know you'd be like wow he's so
smart like Nicky Jam the business man
like taking part of this company blowing
it up that jacket whatever like even
that is valuable he's here this has been
huge for me like right case Wes hadn't
been hot for 20 years Ice T's a long
time ago okay k-swiss
I did a collaboration yeah this was the
first one right and this was a
limited-edition thing I just didn't
manage anything sir that's classy
oh look and that's what you need to be
thinking about if I'm you I think you
think you're having your second act I
think you're looking at Hublot and
[ __ ] whether it's supreme or [ __ ]
Pepsi as like the thing that's anointing
you I'd reverse it I would think about
your life over to your whole life and
think about what you've with or if
you're neutral look what I did
I was neutral but I didn't want to do
Nike in others I want to k-swiss
cuz I'm getting the juice for bringing
it back if you bring back Nautica you
win got it
well that's already been bad right but
if you were the reason champion came
back your career would be different for
the rest of your life not just riding
supreme or off-white got it you've got
too much juice right now I would back to
me just get thrown out some ideas I go
really look at some brand in Columbia
and bring it to America if you make if
you build a brand here in America around
something in Columbia that makes jobs
for everybody now you're talking about
now you're starting to get into 100
percent or like Under Armour did for the
Baltimore area they haven't left they
rejuvenated that area with job the thing
is about these brands having respect for
the Spanish music because you know for
some reason I'm gonna give you an
example and this is what I think I mean
you know I was trying to work something
with adidas in a two minutes okay oh
[Music]
dude I know my man let me say anytime I
know what's gonna come out of your mouth
listen to me you're much more valuable
than they understand because they're not
as hip to the streets as you think
adidas is a corporation will give first
a deal to push a T that has 1 million
followers that may have to let me see it
every day when I told k-swiss who we
should quit the list they gave me and
hip hop I laughed I'm like you're just
thinking big companies look backwards
you're asking people who don't have a
pulse so it's not a language barrier
it's not definitely not because they've
picked other people and honestly to be
very honest with you you already went
through this path you stopped making
excuses if I mute you know lucky
corporate America is that I'm not a
rapper my the song I would have put out
right now about adidas
darris adidas is hot right now for
another few minutes they have a moment
adidas but the truth is always the thing
to sing on you know what I mean
I think it's gang I mean like I think
the number one thing I would do is what
the establishment like adidas and
supreme would be at the top of my list
of things I'd go after not with okay
especially if I had a reason I wouldn't
just do it
but like if you have a reason and you
can do some silly stuff like you don't
them be like like you can do it you can
do it your way but I'd have something
for three stripes I'd make some sort of
you all make my fourth stripe you know
like you know that means like you said
I'm going yeah don't you or do you like
Columbia's three yeah like I would this
is just being creative like I would I
would like be like three stripes didn't
want to with me the only three stripes
without of colors of you then you list
off the club colors of Columbia that's
me that just can sums up exactly what I
would do if you listen to everything I
talked about for the last 30 minutes
everything everything but see where I'm
going you do that if you disobey just
for not with you heavy and you gave love
to Columbia all in one line explode and
then God forbid sales of adidas declined
by 4% in Columbia after that dropped now
you're showing your power listen listen
you've been through this game take every
you've taken a macro know you got a
macro you that's why you rose like a
phoenix take every micro know you have
right now and let that feed you you're
looking for one last validation that the
top fifty are playing at that top fifty
doesn't mean
it's over you know I don't give a [ __ ]
about getting co-signed by the top 100
I'm the new top 100 it's just a matter
of time and he's doing cool organic I
know we got to go but he's doing a song
with Vin Diesel and that's because
they're actually friends you know like
like reals
yeah at least that's not alone you've
won the second you drop giving a [ __ ]
about this last 1% right
Pepsi adidas those celebrities that
network is the second you take that next
step that dangerous step will undo thank
you so much
[Music]